you know the game fmk no never heard of
it Mary kill Sauce Cheese dough I'm not
playing this game
as the host of pizza
's most legendary Pizza makers if you're
somebody using the pizza if you're
somebody who's into spicy food both of
these pizzas smack but now I'm setting
out on a new mission to better
understand the past present and future
of New York Pizza what makes Brooklyn so
special it's more about Community Family
and the commitment to being great to
truly understand New York City you have
to get to know its life shops the OG
legends that set the blueprint to the
boundary pushing newcomers that are
changing the game for good more places
are bringing elevated Pizza to the
masses the Murat is the most popular
definitely stop so vodka pie is ready
and the old school slice shops have had
to adapt and change or they are getting
wiped out
I want to know what it takes to feed New
Yorkers whether it's learning the
secrets behind the city's iconic dollar
slice what do you think about the dollar
slides being raised to a dollar fifty so
we got standard ground yeah
or seeing it by half what it takes to
survive a shift at a real deal Pizzeria
I've worked in plenty of professional
kitchens but pizza shops different I
feel overwhelmed up let's just win let's
go I'm on a quest to sharpen my skills
in the kitchen and discover some of New
York's best slices in the process and of
course I'm meeting up with some friends
along the way when you die you're God's
Pizza you're gonna make the pizza for
God to me it's a prototypical New York
slice except on like the highest level I
never forget that first bite it was like
wow who's coming with me
[Music]